I'm a big fan of standup comedy by which
I mean I watch a lot of old nor McDonald
videos but sometimes I like other
comedians too one thing that's annoying
about stand-up comedy is when they make
political jokes it's usually against the
right I'm not saying men are toilets but
which is fine there plenty of funny
observations to make about conservatives
and Republicans and everything but it
just it's so tedious and it's always
attacking the right my whole life just
all these George Bush jokes and always
really lazy stupid jokes so anyway
sometimes sometimes
comedians attack the left like these
guys who I have not yet
seen allegedly attacking Joe Biden
you're a ly dogac pony soldier producers
take it away we live in a really uh
interesting time we're living in uh Joe
Biden's America yeah Joe Biden is my
favorite President to hear speak why cuz
I like
riddles every time he on TV it's like a
new adlib you know he's like folks folks
I was a little boy America was a small
town marry I broke my elbow
Fu broken elbow ages four to n Go go to
go the do doctor was also the mayor
folks die you didn't pay them any money
you you give them G garlic bread yeah
give him a whole bushel of garlic bread
folks said Dr mayor garlic bread you see
what the that's the president that was a
good Biden impression CU it was a true
impression it wasn't an impersonation it
was just a an impression From a Certain
and the thing he got about Biden was the
you know and and with the folks too and
so everyone who does an impression
usually starts out by doing an
impression of someone else doing an
impression especially young comedians so
his impression was clearly influenced by
Dana carvey's impression of Biden which
is pretty good too my father you know
lost his job no kidding not choking
around but but Dana carvey's version is
is it's less on that
ejaculation emphasis it's more it's more
as hey come on come on hey folk hey come
on come on and so that young guy took
that and then he added that new
dimension was pretty good a good bit I
like that made me laugh next one you
notice that Biden's got a little Feist
here lately cuz when he first came out
he was like a soothing Grandpa offering
you butterscotch from his coin
purse that right but Biden came out as a
really sleepy sweet Grandpa and he was
like he's always repeating the story you
know yeah I went to scr Scranton I grow
up in Scranton
Pennsylvania my dad my dad lost his
job no joke I'm not kidding around
here no no human being in the world
thinks that's a joke then he would do
the number thing number one the one part
number two what the guy said number
three you know the drill come
on no we don't now what he does is he
kind of Whispers And then he yells he's
like we know how to get natural gas cuz
we can get it we know how to get it
that's what we do we get the people of P
that's one public the private Pirates of
the
Caribbean wow that
was I would say providential or just
arranged that way by The
Producers because Dana carvey's
impression the initial impression he did
was what he says was the initial
oratorical rhetorical strategy of of Joe
Biden and it has changed over time and
it has gotten angrier and it has the the
crescendos have become more sudden and
of course a an amazing perhaps Peerless
impressionist like Danny Harvey yes
understood that before the rest of us
did I turn on the new I saw KLA Harris
was in Jakarta and she was in an
interview with a journalist and during
the interview the journalist asked her
if she would be ready willing and able
to take up the office of president if
Biden was for whatever reason
incapacitated and she said yes and it
was just too quick that was that's way
too fast and don't get me wrong that's
literally her job her job to be there in
case he not there she there right that's
her whole job but she said yes like she
been dropping banana pels at the White
House for
years that's way too
fast and so then she started
backtracking which just made it sound
worse she was like I I I'm just
answering you're hypothetical like you
the one over here asking a question
about but bu stronger than
ever I love Hunter I really do cuz I'm
just so
glad that the first
person to smoke crack in the White House
was white
that's that's beautiful that is
absolutely incredible especially if you
know the history of crack in the US
you're like wow
yes yeah that's a pretty good bit the
the first part was kind of weak to me
because it's just a joke about how the
vice presidents want the president to
die which is not specific enough because
it's true of of any
presidency they they just want to be
president so you know it was a little
weak in general and then I liked it
though when he said it's not just that
she said it too fast is that she said it
too fast and been backtracked and they
kind of Wonder well I don't know I'm
just answering the hypothetical that
that got a little bit better and then
the specificity of I'm glad the first
guy to smoke crack at the White House is
Hunter that that's funnier and then
you're digging a little bit
more okay he's a young guy he'll you
know it's got potential when you want to
protect your data you've got to go to
expressvpn.com
YT as you know there are a lot of people
who want to look at what you are doing
online the government the isps the big
tech companies they all are digging into
your stuff and so you should use the
number one rated VPN on the market
expressvpn head on over there right now
we've got all sorts of great deals and
promos if you are a listener and a
viewer of this show do not wait you got
to go immediately over to
expressvpn slm letter Y lettert that is
expressvpn.com
slm YT today folks the American people
are the strongest pumpkins in the world
look talking about the people of
Pittsburgh California California
Pennsylvania man you got the Iron Fist
long sexy legs you work with the hair on
your backs man look that's what it's all
about it's American Spirit like Casper
the Friendly ghoul folks I understand
I'm an American born and bred and raised
man sporn in row and O Colony 16001
Virginia look we didn't know how to hunt
we had feather pens they were 3 ft long
we' write letters to each other and wear
dresses but that's okay folks 609 came
we ate each other but we learn May for
sure a couple Indians died but we made a
mistake that's
America this a really good one because
it's it's mostly about the Cadence which
he he has pretty well I was going to
foot him foot the diction is good too
the the the moving from one topic to
another in ways that are not totally
connected at all but it's it's a
physical impression because he gets it
around the eyes really from cheekbones
up he gets a little bit of that Joe
Biden thing you know he get he gets that
and and the folks I didn't realize how
much the folks really matters come on
hey yeah good Joe Biden is the spare
tire of
presidents that's the nicest thing you
could say about Joe
Biden Joe Biden is a spare tire won't
last long not a permanent
solution it is possible he might get us
closer to where we need to go and we're
only using him because before that we
were riding on the rim as it shoots
orange sparts into the
cabin I got to go but KLA Harris is just
that AAA driver that never shows up we
did Joe I've never seen you again it's
not bad it's yeah fighting has a spare
tire didn't you know it's a
straightforward joke simple joke it's
not not not as many layers he's the
president of the United States like he's
a symbol of our power of our
strength our enemies are
watching can't be falling off bikes on
camera not on camera you do that on your
own
time if I was a terrorist I would have
been like attack get get
these they're vulnerable hit the button
send
it they not ready he can't cross the
street yeah sure I agree with the point
it's not it's true can one more layers
though kind of subversions of
expectations it's a good I'm not
knocking him I'm glad he's making a joke
about how Biden's a jerk
but more twists and turns there speaking
Alzheimer's Joe Biden uh
was I'm not even going to get political
here it's just crazy to me that we have
a president that's definitely going to
die on
camera
it's definitely going to
happen it's not even going to be like an
assassination he's just going
to I know when it's going to happen I
know when it's going to be during his
12th booster
shot going to jab his arm his eyes going
to pop
out it's great the best part about that
bit one you I like the subversion of
expectations where he says I'm not even
going to get political but this man is
definitely going to die on camera so
gets extremely offensive and this also
might be the first funny example of prop
comedy I've ever seen prop comedy might
be the lowest form of Comedy whatsoever
is a seat belt for rednecks but with
this guy you don't know that he's about
to do prop comedy because the only thing
in his hand is the microphone which
every comedian has but then he says yeah
you know like he's going to get his 12th
booster shot and his ey's going to pop
out and you say wait why would getting a
booster shop pop your eye out oh because
that's just the only thing he can
express with the prop he's got and it
pops out and he's holding it by the cord
and it's just very funny it just
actually works so good it good like you
know still my the way I watch Comedy is
I look up old nor McDonald's videos but
some of those were enjoyable see you
next time title undetermined at this
point chairman of the board oh all right
do something with that you
freak I I bet the board is spelled b o r
e
d